someone asked does cold exist the answer
is
no because if it existed you can get as
much of it as you wanted and continue to
make a temperature colder and colder and
colder but there is a lowest possible
temperature where the vibration of all
Atomic and molecular
motion is at a minimum that there's no
temperature below that we call that
absolute zero a whole brand new
temperature scale was invented to
accommodate this fact it's called the
Kelvin scale so right cold does not
exist in that sense but that means heat
exists heat energy so you can get as
much heat energy as you can pack into a
volume sure you could have temperatures
in the trillions of degrees which is
what the early Universe sported right at
the time of the Big Bang so you can say
I feel cold but what you really feel is
the absence of
heat